hi i'm mike coleman a developer advocate
at google cloud
many years back my friend keith and i
were replacing a blown head gasket on my
car i went to remove a bolt with an
adjustable wrench and keith stopped me
cold in my tracks he then said something
that has stuck with me ever since always
use the right tool for the job as he
handed me an appropriately sized box
wrench
we are seeing this advice play out today
in the way organizations are leveraging
the cloud they are choosing different
cloud providers for different workloads
based on a variety of factors in an
effort to ensure they're using the right
tool for the job at hand however using
multiple cloud providers comes with
added complexity in the form of multiple
management interfaces disparate policy
enforcement and complex security
implications
in this video i want to talk a bit about
how anthos can help reduce the
complexity around multi-cloud kubernetes
deployments with a very specific focus
on microsoft's azure
[Music]
before we move into anthos on azure
let's talk about anthos in more general
terms anthos provides a unified platform
for managing kubernetes clusters across
different clouds as well as on-prem
these clusters can be running inside of
virtual machines and instances as well
as on bare metal
anthos is comprised of an integrated set
of services developed to ensure the
entire it organization operators
developers security teams can accomplish
their duties without a siloed approach
anthos is made up of several different
components such as container management
anthos provides a reliable and efficient
way to deploy and run containers
service management
anthos features a managed service mesh
offering to connect manage and secure
vms and containers
policy management
anthoconfig management provides a
central place to manage configuration
and security policies across your entire
fleet
operations management
anthos is integrated with cloud logging
and cloud monitoring to provide an
integrated logging and monitoring
service for containers services and
application
specific to multi-cloud anthos allows
you to manage clusters on google cloud
aws and azure
now let's dive a little deeper into
anthos on azure
when you deploy an anthos on azure
cluster you end up running a compliant
kubernetes cluster on azure native
resources this cluster can be accessed
via the cloud console
gcloud command line or kubectl just like
any other kubernetes cluster
additionally as we'll see in the demo
later the cluster will show up alongside
clusters provisioned in other
environments such as google cloud aws or
bare metal inside of the google cloud
console
the anthocon azure architecture is
comprised of several components the
first is a multi-cloud cluster api this
is a standard google cloud rest api
which provides cluster crud operations
several azure specific parameters are
passed such as the subscription id the
v-net id and the subnet id along with
parameters for the cluster size and
configuration
next we have the multi-cloud cluster
controller when a cluster is created
using the anthous multi-cloud api a
long-running operation is created with
the google cloud-based cluster
controller this controller will create
the cluster in azure asynchronously you
can check the status of the cluster
operation via a get cluster call to the
api
next we have anthos service account
once the anthous multi-cloud api is
enabled on your google cloud project a
google managed service account will be
automatically created within your
project this service account will be the
security principle calling the azure
apis
additionally we have the anthos app
registration in order for the cluster
controller to create azure resources
within your subscription using the antho
service account an azure application
registration must be created within the
azure active directory finally there's
the connect api in order to integrate
into the google cloud console a connect
agent running on the cluster makes an
outbound tls call to the connect api
in any cloud environment there are
multiple different types of resources
deploying anthous is no different
however because anthos automates the
life cycle of the cluster some resources
are managed by anthos while others are
managed by you well now that you have an
understanding of how anthos on azure
clusters are built and managed let's
take a look at a quick demo to give you
a first hand look at how it all comes
together
the first thing i'm going to do is
create what we're calling a client which
is a set of credentials that we can use
to operate against our azure resources
so i've created that client now i'm
going to go ahead and export the
certificate i'm going to take that
certificate and i'm going to upload it
into azure so let's move into the azure
console
and i'll come over here and i'll click
on certificates and secrets
and then i'll do upload certificate and
i'll choose that certificate that we
just created
come down here i'll click the add button
and i now have that certificate uploaded
and i can authenticate against those
azure resources now let's go ahead and
create our control plane cluster you'll
notice here that i'm actually specifying
things like the azure subnet id the vm
size that's specific to azure so a bunch
of azure specific parameters after a few
minutes that cluster will be created so
let's wait for it to finish there it is
so we got the control plane up and
running now let's go ahead and add the
node pool
so a lot like the last command when we
issue this we'll put in some azure
specific parameters to create that node
pool so we'll give that a couple of
minutes fast forward the video
and that node pool will be created as
well
now if we move up to the azure console
we can actually see all those resources
we just created using gcloud so using
the google command line we were able to
go in and provision things like nics and
vms uh ip addresses load balancers all
of those azure resources now if we want
the cluster to show up in google cloud
we need to do uh create a hub membership
so we'll create the hub membership and
we'll install the connect agent on that
cluster and that will allow it to show
back up in the google cloud console so
if i move over there there's our cluster
so if i click on the name you can get
details about the cluster
we can go up and click on the nodes we
can explore the details there
and again these are the same
vms that we saw running in the azure
console and if i come up to storage you
can actually even see the names of those
disks and you can see like
disk.csi.azure.com
and those are azure resources now i
don't have any workloads running just
that connect agent i installed earlier
so let me do
a quick uh deployment of a micro
services demo so we'll do the kubernetes
deployment ammo here create a bunch of
services we'll move back we'll refresh
our workloads notice how we're using the
google cloud console to look at the
workloads running up in azure so that's
that single pane of glass so um they're
not all running yet refresh give a
second and everything's up and running
now if i move over here and i click on
the left on services and ingress i can
find the ip address of the azure based
load balancer and i can click on that
and we'll see our application running so
we'll click here there's the application
running on kubernetes deployed from
google cloud into azure well there you
have it that's anthos on azure for
additional information check out the
links below and don't forget to like and
subscribe to be alerted when we create
fresh new content
[Music]
you